HI Michael.
>> Hey how's it going?
>> So I want to talk about something today Michael.
I want to talk about Bayesian Learning, and I've been inspired
by our last discussion on learning theory to think a
little bit more about what it is exactly that we're trying
to do. I'm in the mood beyond specific algorithms to
just think more generally The sort that learning people want us
to do, learning theory people want us to do and I
think Bayesian Learning is a nice place to start. Sound fair?
>> Yeah, that sounds really cool, I think
that might be a nice formal framework for thinking about some of these problems.
>> Good. Good. So, I'm going to start out. By
making a few assertions, which I hope you will
agree with, and if you agree with this then
we'll be able to kind of move forward and ask
some pretty cool questions okay? So Bayesian learning, so
the kind of idea here behind Bayesian learning is
this sort of fundamental Underlying assumption about what we're
trying to do with the machine learning. So, I've written
it down here, here's what I'm going to claim
we're trying to do. We are trying to learn
the best hypothesis we can given some data and
some domain knowledge. Do you buy that as an assertion?
>> Yeah, it's, and pretty much everything we've talked about so far
has had a form kind of like that. We're searching through a hypothesis
base and As you've pointed out on multiple occasions there's this kind
of extra domain knowledge that comes into play for example when you pick
a like a similarity metric for something like k nearest neighbors
>> Right and of course we always have the
data because we're machine learning people and we always have
data. So this is what we've been trying to do
and I'm going to suggest that we can be a
little bit more precise about what we mean by
best and I'm going to try to do that and
see if you agree with me. Okay, so I'm going
to rewrite what I've written already except I'm replacing best
with most probable. Okay. So what I'm going to claim is that what
we've really been trying to do with all these algorithms we're doing is
we're trying to learn the most likely or the most probable hypothesis
given the data and whatever domain knowledge we bring to bear. You buy that?
>> Interesting. I'm not sure yet. I mean, so is it
the hypothesis that it's most likely to be returned by the algorithm?
>> No, it's the hypothesis
that we think is most likely, given the data that we've seen.
Given the training set and given whatever domain knowledge that we bring to
bear on the problem, the best hypothesis is the one that is
most likely, that is Most probable. Or most l, probably the correct one.
>> Interesting. Well, are we going to be able to connect that to what we
were talking before? Which is generally we were
selecting hypotheses based on things like their error.
>> Yes. Exactly. We are going to be able to connect that.
We are definitly going to be able to connect that. But.
>> Okay.
>> I can;t go forward unless I can convince
you that it's reasonable to at least start out thinking
about best being the same thing as most probable. Yeah,
I'm willing to go forward with this. It sounds interesting.
>> So if you're willing to move forward with this, then I want to write
one more thing down and then we can sort of dive into it. So if
you buy that we're trying to learn the most probable hypothesis, the most likely
one, the one that has the highest chance of being correct given the data, and
our domain knowledge, then we can write that
down in math speak pretty simply. It's the
probability of, some particular hypothesis h, drawn from
some hypothesis class. Given some amount of data
which I'm just going to refer to as D
from now on. Okay? And that's just, exactly
what we said just above when we talk
about the most probable age, given the data. Okay?
>> Well wait. Two things. One is so D
is not distribution which we've had in the past.
>> That's true.
>> So I
guess as long as we keep that straight. And the other one is
No that's, you're just telling me
the probability of some particular hypothesis h.
>> That's right. So, we want to somehow,
given this quantity we want to find, the
best or the, most likely, of the hypothesis given this. Does that make sense?
>> Yes.
>> So we want to find the argmax, of h, drawn from Your hypothesis class.
That is we want to find the hypothesis drawn from
the hypothesis class that has the highest probability given the data.
>> Perfect.
>> Okay, good. So we're going to spend the next 45 hours.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Exploring this expression.
>> Okay so that's like what, like 6 hours per letter.
>> [LAUGH] Yeah and that's fine because its important.